That
firing
range is Rin's area,
no, I'm in there.Forced to not let him hit it.Maybe it's a
bruise, but Nagi read it perfectly.There's
almost no shot course.That's
why it sticks.I
invited him to fake a shot and made me rush in.Rin is better than
me because of this time loss.  I can catch up,
nice
[Music]
It's like, oh no, will it
help? There's
going to be some shooting or greed between us, no way.
This is also the day I want to see a fake. Do
n't miss the time when we have to make a decision.
Everyone on the field is being made to dance.
Even without causing a price reaction, he is a
monster who can create countless variations by himself.It
seems like he has learned how to use his eyes on the field,
but such lukewarm soccer
doesn't make my heart sing.